LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, and
welcome to this episode
of Geocast, where we walk
you through what you can
do with the Google Maps APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Laurence Maroney,
and in today's episode,
I'm going to talk about one of
my favorite parts of the Google
Maps APIs--
the ability to draw on a map
with polygons and polylines,
and the new ways that
you can style them.
If you aren't already familiar
with polygons and polylines,
they're very useful tools to
help make your maps work better
for your users.
They allow you to
draw shapes on a map
so that you can delineate areas.
So, for example,
maybe you want to show
the route of your walkabout
in the Australian outback.
You can do that by
drawing a polyline
between different
geographic points.
Here you can see my desired
one from Melbourne to Darwin
through both Adelaide and Perth.
That's a long walk and
a bit of a swim, too.
Or maybe you want to
play a game on a map
with a square showing
an area of interest.
You can do that by drawing
a polygon around the area,
like here, where I've defined
the boundaries for the world's
biggest game of hide and seek.
In this video, I'll show
you how to style these.
If you're interested in custom
styling beyond your polys,
we have a video for that,
too, and there's a link
to it in the description below.
There are lots of options,
including stroke patterns
for outlines, such as dashed,
dotted, or mixed, all of which
can be defined the
way that you want
to give your users the
best possible experience.
You can set different
ends for your line,
including having rounded
ends, [? butt ?] ends,
and square ends, or
indeed a custom end,
like the arrow shown here.
And there's a whole
lot more that you
can do, such as line weight
and being able to set
the color of lines and fills.
In this example,
I have a polyline
which shows my desired
walkabout of Australia.
I'm going to zoom into
the lovely city of Perth,
and you'll see where my line
takes a turn at a bus stop.
I can now customize
the color of the line,
its alpha transparency, its
width, how the segments join
together, such as having a
bevel or rounded corners,
as well as the
pattern for the line.
Here are some examples that
are built into the sample app,
but you can customize your own.
Polygons are similar.
Let's take a look.
Here you can see my
map of the boundaries
for the world's biggest
ever game of hide and seek.
It's a polygon with a couple
of holes for no go areas.
Eh, lots of dingos
there, apparently.
And it's a polygon
which can be filled,
and its color can be changed,
as can its opacity or alpha.
The weight of the stroke
outlining the polygon
can be changed, as can
its color and opacity.
If I go to one of
the corners, we
can look at the stroke joint.
The joint can be the default, or
it could be beveled or rounded.
You can see the default now.
But I can change it to
be beveled or rounded,
which really shows up nicely
in a contrasting color.
Like with the polygon, the
stroke pattern can also be set,
but you aren't limited to these.
You can define your
own, and you can
see what some of the options
are, like dashed, dotted,
or mixed.
And, of course, changing
the weight of the stroke
will impact how these look
at different zoom levels.
But wait, there's more!
Not only can you
style your polys,
you can also attach
custom data to them.
You're probably familiar with
custom data being attached
to markers, but now you can
put it on polygons, polylines,
circles, and ground overlays.
It's as easy as setting
a tag on your shape,
and then in the
OnClickListener, you
can read it back and
do something with it.
Here's a simple
example of a toast.
And here's what it will
look like at runtime
where, if someone
is using my app,
and they don't know
what that polygon is,
a simple click will show
them that it's my hide
and seek boundary.
So that's a quick taste of
some of the great styling
features found in polygons,
polylines, and other shapes
in Google Maps.
We hope you enjoyed this
Geocast and can't wait
to see what you build with it.
You can learn more about these
features and a whole lot more
on the Google Maps
Developer site.
Go check it out.
Don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.
[MUSIC PLAYING]